because you don't know if I'm gonna have
something in this you know breakable
yeah that was all like and he's like
yeah
he's like give me half up
[Music]
I'm not even gonna say nothing just
watch this and uh good luck it looks sad
dude
this is probably a only sad one today oh
man
this house right here oh I know this one
just keep looking at that house right
there I'm waiting to see a blow up yeah
dude
you do
I put it in the wrong house
I know you did just so I did that I'm
like I'm waiting to see a blow up and
the one house he planned
we got the wrong house
well the other one
don't make me a Devilicious expert
yeah look at right there at the End of
the Street crazy dude
surprise ring got that that is crazy did
you guys I saw so the aftermath of this
yeah in that video it doesn't show the
two houses next to it blown up but then
the aftermath the two houses are gone oh
[__] yeah and I think it it caught on
fire or something Gastly yeah yeah it
was a ghastly caused by fanny pack
classic happens you know what's crazy
this happened the same week Lahaina
burnt down so it just felt like the
whole world was burning yeah
so that that fanny pack comments because
this fool wears a fanny pack and
sometimes he doesn't notice that he
turned his stove on when he turns yeah
and he like hit the switch on the stove
and he had a guess he had a gas tank
that could have been your house can I
tell you something these guys are trying
to make a fool out of me you are a fool
though
[Laughter]
like this man what you see how that how
they're how they're spreading lies on my
name dude you are a fool
I'm not disagreeing with that well those
are the two houses next to it you see
that yeah that's a nice pool but
this little house
is that a seven footer that little house
was safe diving board huh
you know where to go Nick
so there's a is there anybody get hurt
yeah there's six deaths oh man this is
not funny after you tell me that I know
it's funny it's funny I think people are
still laughing yeah it's funny it's
funny come on come on no all six were
sex offenders
kidding that's not funny that's not true
because if that happened
if that was like a group home for sex
yeah
everybody
everybody's attitude was just like oh
they deserved it
yeah yeah blow them up
it was like but they were like in their
like four of them or I believe were in
their 50s there was one guy in his 30s
and then there was a kid and it's like
12. oh so it's like a family yeah son of
a [__] yeah but there's a weird thing
going on where they still haven't
determined the exact cause obviously
it's some type of gasoline but I think
there's a strange chance that it's a gas
leak from like a Tesla nah it's like a
it there might be a liability with the
city of in some way oh [__] yeah and I
think they're trying to disprove that
right now so yeah of course is it like
they left the stove on or is it like the
city
yeah the city left it on they didn't
patch up there yeah this guy was like
all right you're all good and he had a
fan back on they have tool belts dude
they're pretty heavy
all I'm saying I think um I think I read
something about it this could just be
like one like a conspiracy thing but I
did read something about like there's a
city uh like a natural gas reserve
somewhere and there's a line that could
have leaked into their system that's so
[__] and if that's the case there oh
because that's that to me is so much gas
it can't be like gas stove no exactly
yeah that doesn't it at least three
houses yeah that looks like a gas tank
like commercial gas right yeah and then
shock wave too for the aftermath like
reaching all the way to that other house
that probably yeah it probably blew your
windows out if you knocking wind chimes
off of porches and [__] like Yeah The
Rim camera there's [__] I'm not gonna
know when times capital offense right
there so even the kid was a sex offender
yeah started early huh that's right they
catch everything
I know anything to feel better about
this that was on a ring camera right
yeah yeah you know I I I just got a ring
camera for the first time don't you hate
them
I thought it was pretty funny because I
caught the mailman oh man it was doing
freaking beautiful so I was uh I was in
like my carport working on my garage if
I were working on my car and uh the
mailman was coming dropping off packages
in front of our house
and uh
so I see him walk I didn't say anything
to him and then he just like he has a
one of my packages like this and just
like drops it onto the ground so I heard
like a loud flat like pop pop on the
ground I'm like what the [__] dude
they'd be doing that and then he goes
upstairs and then just like throws the
the other bag I just thought up there
and I'm just like there's a regular
mailman like that yeah he just slams
and he's a regular
he's doing some UPS stuff
windmill ducks
so then he start he he comes down and
I'm like excuse me sir I was like next
time I was like can you put my uh can
you handle my package like a little more
carefully can you set it down next time
because you don't know if I'm gonna have
something in this you know breakable
yeah that was all like and he's like
yeah
he's like give me half up and he was
like he was like what are you talking
about I set it down so I got a video of
him actually so you're like oh really
let me show you
so he's like what do you mean so he goes
and grabs the package he's like I set it
down like this and then he drops it
again and I'm like sir don't sit here
and lie to me he's like what are you
talking about I was like sir do you see
that I got a ring camera right there and
then next thing you know he changed his
whole attitude he was like oh you know I
sorry sir you know I didn't mean it
yeah how do you just you know yeah you
didn't break anything but I was just
like yo just
[Laughter]
so this I I recently saw this guy he has
like a ring camera right like a like a
home surveillance thing yeah and it's a
compilation of him [__] up thieves
huh yeah and then I guess this apartment
complex always gets jacked right so
you'll see like cars pull up and then
this this guy's like he walks outside he
goes
oh yeah and he clocks his gun oh yeah
dude that guy's sick and he's like
pistol whipping the car and breaking all
their Windows bro he's terrorizing these
people bro they're like we're sorry
inside of the garage and he's and he's
and he just starts pointing guns at him
and yeah they start freaking the [__]
out you see you hear them melt and
they're running into their car for their
[__] life dude yeah they'll be in his
garage like trying to rummage through
[__] and he just pops out of nowhere
with a bat and starts beating the [__]
out of them yeah dude yeah damn pretty
gangster but there's where is he at my
apartment complex right you deaf
my dude is sick there's like four or
five he gets robbed a lot but yeah I'm
like I'm trying to think he leaves his
garage door open a little bit I think no
I would do it too you know but kind of
tight though you know
you're gonna take the bait yeah then
you're an [__] yeah all everyone here
has ring or Nest on their door I have
both I have both I have Nest cams and I
have a ring what yeah you know what's
funny I actually had just bought a ring
right and it came in I haven't installed
it yet and then I sat down here in our
last session and then somebody brought a
ring and all of you guys consistently
together like yo Rings sucked yeah I
don't like I don't like my I like Nest
better yeah so then immediately I went
home and Nina returned it good oh she
did yeah we don't get Nest I feel like
there's always a delay on my ring well
yeah it always catches catch the
beginning that's why I was surprised at
this [__] this uh this video actually
caught these could be it could be a nest
I don't know oh no because usually you
see the last like two to three seconds
and you go oh great well also to be fair
a lot of what it catches is also at the
fault of how you set it up no I've set
it up right dude
I [__] set up so good because not
everybody wants it to record all the
time no dude I record it all the time if
you program your zones incorrectly my
zone is so good it's the widest zone are
you programmed for animals people yeah
everything dude everything not Cars yeah
because I I was managing an Airbnb for a
while and we used ring um
can you come over and check out my right
now
[Laughter]
[Music]